i'm lucy james reading for reviewer
suriel vazquez
the first time i beat the final boss in
hades i felt an enormous
sense of relief i'd been fighting to see
this ending for hours and in roguelikes
it feels better than usual to see an
ending i was definitely a little too
proud of putting together a set of
abilities and perks that shredded the
boss
after they wrecked me just a few tries
ago but that wasn't why i felt tears
welling up
i'd gotten so caught up in the story of
zagreus and the heroes villains and gods
that had helped him get here
that i was elated to have finally gotten
him to the end of his journey
what sets hades apart isn't just that
it's a great roguelike with the kind of
repeatable depth that makes it
engrossing to play for hours
but also how he uses its structure to
tell an ongoing story about family
secrets and resolution i can do this
i can do this
[Music]
that hades narrative is so entwined with
its combat
is nothing new for supergiant games
who've established themselves as masters
of putting your actions in sync with the
stories they tell
in a roguelike such as hades it means
playing as zagreus
a god of rebirth tired of living under
his father haiti's thumb
and seeking answers about where he comes
from he sets out to escape to the world
of the living
battling undead monsters living
creatures and mythological figures on
his way out
your godliness justifies the endless
runs through the depths of the
underworld and one of the best parts of
hades
is returning to the house of hades every
time you die
it's not just a pit stop on the way to
the next run it's the centerpiece hades
hinges on
there figures like achilles hypnos and
nicks
console you after your deaths praise you
for making progress
and confide in you about one another
eventually they become
vital allies on your quest even if
they're not in the thick of combat with
you
these interactions as much as the
precise combat are the reason i kept
coming back to hades
while i was skeptical about how the
roguelike structure would meld with
supergiant games focused on characters
and stories they've written and voiced
reams of dialogue and lore
and almost all of it is delivered with
vigor and is intriguing enough to pull
over between your tracks through hell
i know you're right of course you're
right
i'll do my best when you finally decide
to take another stab at escaping
runs are broken up into a few different
worlds each made up of several randomly
ordered chambers
hades combat builds on bastion's tight
isometric fights
and infuses them with the endlessly
repeatable appeal of random buffs
modifiers random enemy layouts
currencies and progression
that slowly turn the seemingly
impossible task of reaching the surface
into something manageable combat is
quick and reactive letting you chain
attacks into dashes
dashes into special moves and so on as
you learn how to whittle enemy shields
avoid traps and work over bosses all six
weapons you can equip
push you to play differently and weapon
specific modifiers nudge you towards
using different parts of your tool set
that and how buffs interact in myriad's
surprising and effective ways
means i'm still not tired of making
these runs dozens of hours later
in more crowded fights the switch's
smaller screen makes text and combat
readability an issue as these chambers
are large enough to lose details
and runs and even here tantalizing
narrative threads
seep through most buffs called boons are
tied to individual gods
if you want that deflect you're going to
have to ask athena for it while artemis
is in charge of critical damage
these short exchanges give each god a
distinct personality and reflect your
actions and progress
you also occasionally catch clues about
a potential side quest or plot thread
that ties into the larger narrative
i liked athena artemis and dionysus not
just because their boons were
consistently useful
but because i took to athena's austere
will artemis's prickly reclusiveness
and the laid-back flirtiness of dionysus
hey there zag man how's it going look
you have got to get here with the rest
of us already we've been saving you a
spot
these conversations are more than
narrative icing you can give the gods
gifts and
build your relationships with them too
occasionally you'll run into rooms where
you can score two boons but only after
choosing one god
and facing the wrath of the other as you
progress through hell you'll start
seeing
those boons used against you so for as
much as the gods pay lip service to want
to meet them on olympus
your journey to escape torment is little
more than a spectacle to them
a game to watch and manipulate from the
sidelines does that threat lead
anywhere it's hard to say because hades
unfurls so many other threads like it as
you play
eventually you meet characters that
sprinkle interesting bonuses into your
runs while simultaneously launching new
side stories back in the house of hades
and even bosses change over the course
of multiple runs
[Music]
um how about no no murder no murder
supergiant has managed to turn the
roguelike a genre not usually known for
riveting plots
into a compelling vehicle for
storytelling the random nature of the
genre does mean the kind of climactic
moments that define traditional stories
are hard to come by
but i loved that rather than face an
imposing boss learning about a new twist
of fate and then moving on to the next
act
you have hundreds of conversations with
your family roommates and enemies
about whatever comes to mind this is
where haiti's bid to tell its story
differently
pays off as playing it eventually feels
like living in a crowded home for months
one where arcs happen but nothing truly
ends
after being chided by hades with a
dismissive back again
after having failed to kill a boss then
listening to everyone around simply
wring their hands about the lord of the
dead
i understood why zagreus would want to
leave the shadow of his overbearing
distant father
that convergence between player and
character motivation is a powerful
feeling
and what supergiant delivers so
brilliantly that long tail approach to
world building may not work for everyone
before i played hades
i didn't see myself as someone who'd
continued to play a roguelike after
beating it but i wanted to keep learning
more about these characters and this
underworld enough
to keep coming back that along with a
robust post game that alters every
weapon and boss
lets you make the game even harder for
more rewards and offers even more
reasons to play an already entrancing
mix of rpg and action combat
has absolutely hooked me when i'm not
playing hades i'm thinking about how
cool it'd be
to build the exogrif machine gun with
lightning boons combo that got me that
first victorious run but also throw in
some critical damage
until we meet again i'm also thinking
about how much i still have left to
learn about hades
both the character and the game like in
the greek myths hades takes inspiration
from
endings aren't tidy and they're almost
never final
they're protracted often unsatisfying
and are hard to find real closure in
and the fact that hades understands this
is its greatest strength
i'm sure there's a point where after
running through hell enough times i'll
have seen all hades has to offer
the story does end but what matters so
much more are all the moments between
the start and end of a story
and the people who help us see those
climactic moments but also stick with us
between them
they're the reason we keep trying and
the reason we keep coming back
[Music]
you